[Music]
if you are looking for a surprise weapon
against the scandinavian defense
in your blitz and the rapid games then
you came to the right place because in
today's lecture
i am going to show you one of my own
patch and tricky line
which you might want to consider as a
complete surprise weapon
in the tournament practice
after e4 and d5
are you ready guys
look at this
a3
and some of you might say is what is
this
and indeed if you put this in leeches
analysis it is considered as a blunder
but sometimes it is amazing how engine
evaluate the position wrong in the
opening stage
the big point is
absolutely no books no videos and nobody
analyzed this position
so as a practical point of view you have
a great chance
that your opponent can get wrong
immediately
now before we dive in the important
point i like to mention here that
all the decline variation i am going to
cover at the end
as if you check the database
by far the most popular choice is
d captures e4
and after this white initiative
literally
run down the ball
here we start with knight to c3
trying to regain the pawn back
and if black has to keep his advantage
then he has to maintain his extra pawn
so accordingly there are two popular
choices
and amongst them the first move f5 which
frequently happen at the lower level
is absolutely bad
whereupon white get tremendous fun
starting with
bishop to c4
so there is already a threat of
capturing this knight and destroying the
black kingside castle ride
so black has to play knight to f6
and after that we play in a true gambit
style
with
d3
let me show you how fun this position is
for the wide
one of my recent game against 2100 to
continue with pawn captures d3 and now
i continue with my lightning fast
development with knight to f3
and if you think that well what about if
black takes the third pawn
well of course he cannot as he can
simply lose his queen
after bishop to f7 check and after king
takes and queen takes white is
completely winning
so that's right out of the equation
and apart from this white has a simple
plan namely knight to g5 and pressurize
this all light squares
well the game finished very quickly my
opponent plays e6
and after i castle
he finally grabbed the third pawn which
i happily take back with the queen
and now he realize
that he has to complete his kingside
development
so bishop to c5
but i'm afraid this is too little too
late as after knight to g5
believe it or not but the game is
finished
black cannot castle due to the threat of
bishop to e6
and in the game he tried to defend the
pawn with queen to e7 which is even the
worst choice as after the simple move
rook to even
black played the final move e5
just to find out his horror that after
knight to f7
white has double threat number one
knight captures rook and the second one
rook takes e5
which more or less complete a opening
disaster for the black camp
so you can see how dangerous this line
is
if your opponent tried to play the move
f5
okay
by far the most sound choice here is
knight to f6
defending the pawn
and now we play the another crafty move
queen to e2
renewing the threat on e4
and black has few choices
amongst them bishop to f5 is the main
line however again we are going to loop
the decline variations such as queen to
d4 and knight to c6 at the end
first bishop to f5 defending the pawn
and now the point behind the move queen
to e2
we can give this nasty check
and the position resemble
the reversed england gambit
where
black has to play very accurately to
avoid lots of tricks and traps
first thing many of your opponent
wouldn't realize
that this bishop is hanging
and if they continue with moves such as
knight bd7 or c6
then they lost the piece just within
the sixth move of the game
this has happened frequently
okay
what about other choices
second bad move black can play over here
is queen to d7
after that our response is very much
natural
queen captures b7
and black's big idea is he wants to
protect his rook with queen to c6
where everything looks so good right
nope just one move bishop to b5 and
black sweetie
disappear from the ball
so queen to d7 is a bad choice by the
black camp
the third move knight to c6 looks bit
reasonable
because now if you take the bishop then
knight to d4 is a very strong reply by
black
however we can continue with our pawn
grabbing
queen takes b7
if bishop to d7 here then bishop to b5
leads to the main line
so the only other good option for the
black here is knight to d4
attacking on the weak c2 square
but here tactics favors the white
we continue with bishop to b5 jack
if knight to d7 then bishop to a4 defend
the threat
so the most natural response here is
bishop to d7
afterwards
we can simply take this guy
if king takes then after king to d1
it's funny that both the king are
misplaced but white is a clear pawn up
and black has some shattered pawn
so that's not a good idea
and the other response knight to d7
can be made with knight to b5
where we have clear threat of knight to
c7
which force black to take this knight
and the end result is
yes material is balanced
but look at the pawn structure of the
black
they are all over the place
and as i highlighted over here with the
simple plan white obviously get a
nagging h
so in a nutshell it is pretty clear that
after this queen check
black has to save his bishop with
bishop to d7
okay we are going to take on b7 our
routine business
and now black is on the cross rule
whether he wants to continue with either
knight to c6 or bishop to c6
well surprisingly as per the database
highestly played move here is bishop to
c6
which is in fact an outright blunder
and at first sight it doesn't look like
because black is defending everything
right
but see yourself
i hope you guessed the white's next move
bishop to b5
and not only we are pinning down this
bishop but now we are renewing the
threat of queen captures rook
and accordingly black has two choices
the first one bishop captures bfa is
absolutely bad
because after knight captures b5
white has now two threads grabbing the
rook as well as
knight to c7 check and unfortunately
black cannot defend both of them
well as per the database knight to d5
has been played highestly here
but i'm afraid this is not saving the
day
as white has a simple tactical resource
yup you guessed it queen catches d5
and the big point is after queen takes
and knight to c7 check
white coming up with a piece up
now the trick which really fascinate me
occurs
when black plays the move queen to d7
counter attacking our queen and trying
to defend this mass
but see yourself as one of the most
deadliest streak happen
after bishop captures c6
queen capture c6 and at first sight it
looks like
hang on black has defend everything
right
but just one move
queen to c8
and we have a picturesque checkmate on
the board
within just ninth move of the game
isn't that wonderful
the most amazing part is there are more
than 120 plus people fall for this
so the chances of occurring in your game
is very high
so that means here black response is
again forced
he has to play knight to c6
and after that white has two choices
amongst them i like the move bishop to
b5
creating the threat on the c6 knight
and accordingly black response is forced
the majority of the games continue with
rook to b8 attacking the queen
queen to e6
still there is a threat on c6 so black
plays rook to b6
and after queen to a4
we reach to the most important junction
of this variation
where
the theory ends and if you put this in
engine
it will say that it is slightly better
for the black
however personally i think
with better preparation it is white who
can dictate the game
black has few choices namely a6 or
either e6 or e5
but the beauty is against all of this
our response is very consistent what we
want to play is we want to reroute this
knight to the g3 square
followed up with the castle
and then
gobble up this e4 pawn
whereupon or white obtain a clear pawn
advantage
so let me show you some sample lines
first move i want to consider is a6
attacking the bishop
whereupon we can chop on c6 and after
bishop takes
and the move queen to c4
we achieve our trom that is
completely shatter black queenside pawn
structure
and on top of everything as i have
highlighted over here white has a simple
plan which give him a slight age in this
variation
so a6
doesn't fit into the black response
the most natural response is liberating
the dark square bishop by playing either
the moon e6 or e5
let's say ifa is engine's most frequent
choice
and after that
yup you guessed it
knight to e2
going for the pressure on the e4 pawn
here black has many choices including
bishop to e7 as well as knight to d4
and to best describe white's overall
plan i like to show you one of my recent
game
where my strong candidate master
opponent continue with bishop to e7
whereupon i castle and when black castle
i simply play knight to g3
so if allowed then white will definitely
take on e4
so my opponent responded with knight to
d4
unleashing the attack on b5
but after bishop takes b5
black is forced to capture with the
queen as if he played the move knight to
d7
then black's two pawns are hanging
namely e4 as well as on a7
so in the game my opponent choose queen
takes d7 but after this queen trade
yes you can take on e4 but i found this
strong continuation namely
knight to d5
double attack
my opponent plays rook to e6
i simply first take on c7
counter-attacking the rook
he played rook to c6
but after knight to d5 rook to e6
and the move knight captures e4
yes for a time being
white is two pawn up
but black can take one of the pawn with
knight capture c2
and when we play rook to b1
i think it's time for the assessment
not only white has extra pawn on b2 but
his knights are wonderfully placed
and overall if you put this position in
any chess engine it is clearly favoring
the white
so i think this model game give you a
great illustration
how to play
when black enters into the mainline
territory
you